almost a year since it shocked the world
and the story of Jamal Kazuki's murder
is still making headlines
there's about newspaper one of turkeys
biggest published details of
conversations that took place between
staff at the Saudi consulate in Istanbul
and officials in the kingdom's royal
court in Riyadh they corroborate with a
narrative that was presented by the
United Nations Special Rapporteur
investigating the murder of the slain
journalist in the findings she published
three months ago further evidence that
Ashok trees killing was not simply a
botched attempt by Saudi agents to
kidnap him but in fact a premeditated
murder according to the Saba newspaper
on September the 28th four days before
her chakra was killed a security attache
stationed at the consulate named
armadale Mazzini telephoned Mohammed rib
an advisor at the royal court of Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman McRib asked
the security attache if Kochi who'd
visited the consulate earlier that day
will indeed return on October the second
yes we are all shocked we just spoke I
said how are you there isn't anything
official but it's known that he is one
of the people's salt later that same day
the Saudi console himself mohammed el
OTB spoke to another individual known
only as a a head of state security
called me and they have an assignment
they need a person from your protocol
for a special and a top secret mission
Shaima Gerber's is an editor the
english-language edition of sabah she
says it's her and her colleagues duty to
continue shedding light on the story
until the entire truth is revealed
against Kalam at the UN reporter said
that Saudi Arabia has a responsibility
in this killing so the thing we are
seeing right now is the ones who are
criminals are judging themselves so it's
of course expected for us to not see
anyone being convicted because it's
basically a chatter rather than a fair
trial that's why I don't think that
we'll see anyone that is truly
being responsible from this murder will
be charged will be convicted in time
salute it was reported that Crown Prince
Mohammed bin Salman was advised by
President Donald Trump's son-in-law and
chief adviser Jared Krishna in the early
days following the killing of Tamil
faculty to weather the storm and that
the story would die in a few months if
not weeks almost one year since jimal
keshavjee was killed in the consulates
behind me and the story is still very
much making headlines not least because
there are several questions that have
not been answered including where is the
body of the slain journalist and why has
nobody been convicted of his murder
until and unless those questions are
answered it is likely that this story
will not be going away jamal al al al
jazeera istanbul